Damir putin's reelection is certain
don't waste your time looking at his
carefully scripted but sterile campaign
for clues to Russia's future instead
look at the three hundred twenty seven
billion dollar defense modernization
program that Putin signed in Sochi on
November 27th after a non-stop for days
session with Russia's top military brass
this in a country where personal incomes
have been going down for four years
growing poverty is a key problem and
social protests are up 56 percent but
that's exactly the point
Russia is effectively at war when he
signed the defense modernization program
Putin called on all Russian enterprises
private estate to be ready to switch to
military production in a time of need as
he put it in order to again a quote
efficiently neutralize external threats
the message is clear
Putin is a wartime president and wartime
presidents are not to be replaced so
long as the war is going on and Putin
his propaganda machine and his generals
will make sure that it is and gets
hotter by the day so what do you think
will happen in Russia after Lattimore
Putin's re-election in March 2018 let us
know in your comments also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AI